Trascrizione: camilla bisesti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera,
iniziamo subito con un piccolo quiz.
Provate a calcolare a mente 10 più 229.
Avete fatto?
Semplice, no?
Provate a farlo adesso.
Temple Grandi, una persona adulta
con sindrome di Asperger,
dice che l'autismo è come un cesto
con molti puzzle diversi,
tutti mescolati fra di loro,
dove c'è confusione
e dove spesso le cose sono poco chiare.
Ognuno di noi ha un'idea di autismo
che non è reale,
perché nessuno di noi sa
come è davvero essere
una persona con autismo.
Ma chi sono, realmente,
le persone con autismo?
E che cos'è realmente questa condizione,
che colpisce un bambino su 100,
e prevalentemente i maschi?
Come vivono la loro vita?
Proviamo a capirlo
attraverso lo sguardo di Paolo,
adulto di 55 anni con autismo.
Nell'immaginario collettivo,
l'autismo è dipinto così:
molti di noi credono
che le persone con autismo
non provino emozioni,
e non siano empatiche.
Ma è davvero così?
"Sono intensamente empatico,
le emozioni delle persone mi attraversano
con forza incontrollata.
Ho imparato presto a muovermi
in punta di piedi, a nascondermi,
perché mostrare come ero e cosa provavo
mi faceva spaventare molto,
e non era possibile.
Il mio mondo era forte, intenso,
ricco di colori, ricchissimo di odori,
iperstimolante, confuso.
Il mio corpo era troppo sensibile:
assorbivo e percepivo tutto,
nel bene e nel male".
Per anni, abbiamo creduto
che l'autismo passasse con la crescita.
E adesso: "A 51 anni
ho saputo d'essere Asperger,
e la confusione
che mi portavo dietro da anni
è svanita come neve al sole,
portando pace e riposo.
Continuerò a dubitare di quello che valgo,
a sentirmi a disagio accanto ai colleghi,
a non sapere cosa ci si aspetta da me,
a non sapere cosa sia opportuno dire,
o non dire, in determinate situazioni,
a detestare il telefono
e a dimenticarmi di tutto e di tutti
quando mi concentro".
Spesso pensiamo che le persone con autismo
abbiano pochi interessi,
ma "disegnare, scrivere e recitare:
ecco cosa mi piace fare quando non lavoro.
Dopo aver disegnato,
mi sento molto meglio.
Mi piace recitare perché ho l'opportunità
di mettermi nei panni degli altri".
A volte crediamo
che le persone con autismo
non provino interesse per gli altri.
"In classe non partecipavo
mai attivamente:
per difficoltà, non per mancato interesse.
E quindi passavo sempre per quello
che non era interessato
agli argomenti o agli altri.
In realtà, facevo molta fatica
a fare nuove amicizie,
anche se lo desideravo tanto".
Per molti anni ci hanno fatto credere
che l'autismo fosse una malattia.
"Non sono una persona malata,
anche se per tanti anni
mi sono sentito tale.
Dare un nome alle mie caratteristiche
mi ha permesso di capire
che funziono solo in un modo diverso".
I falsi miti si basano su pre-giudizi,
cioè sul giudicare prima:
prima di conoscere,
prima di sapere, prima di analizzare.
La scienza ci permette di imparare,
di comprendere, di ragionare,
di studiare, di sperimentare.
La scienza ci guida,
è una luce che illumina
ciò che difficilmente potremmo vedere.
L'ABA è la scienza che si occupa
di analizzare il comportamento umano
e ABA sta per Applied
Behavioural Analysis,
che tradotto in maniera letterale
significa "Analisi applicata
del comportamento".
È la scienza che studia le leggi
che regolano il comportamento umano;
e insieme ad altri interventi,
che hanno evidenza scientifica,
è uno dei tasselli di un grande puzzle
che attraverso la conoscenza
del comportamento umano
ci aiuta e si occupa di osservare
o comprendere ed approfondire
il comportamento
delle persone con autismo.
Ci fa indossare degli occhiali
che ci fanno vedere
con occhi più sinceri, più puliti,
liberi da pre-giudizi.
"Gli interventi con evidenza scientifica
sono più di uno,
e ci aiutano a comprendere
un mondo sottile, delicato, fragile,
un mondo in cui bisogna entrare
in punta di piedi.
L'analisi del comportamento
ci permette di supportare, e sostenere,
le persone con diagnosi di autismo.
Insegnare loro alcuni comportamenti
che possono essere utili
per farle sentire maggiormente integrate
nel nostro contesto sociale,
per farle sentire meno sole.
Supporta le persone con autismo
affinché possano essere più autonome,
a comunicare anche se non emettono suoni,
perché imparino a dialogare
attraverso le immagini,
attraverso i gesti.
Insegna loro a prendere l'autobus,
oppure a cercare un nuovo posto di lavoro.
Ecco: questi sono solo alcuni esempi
di nuovi apprendimenti.
L'ABA è solo un tassello fra tanti,
il tassello di un mosaico
formato da molte altre discipline
che negli anni si sono
occupate di autismo".
Vi racconto adesso la storia di Andrea.
Andrea ha otto anni,
e una diagnosi grave di autismo.
Andrea non sa allacciarsi le scarpe:
eppure, allacciarsi le scarpe
è molto semplice.
Ma siamo sicuri che per una persona
con autismo sia così semplice?
Andrea, attraverso gli strumenti
e le tecniche dell'ABA
l'ha imparato, un passo alla volta.
Concludiamo questo dialogo
con una riflessione di Paolo, che ci dice:
"Quando incontrate
una persona con autismo,
abbiate pazienza, molta pazienza,
anche di più di quella che avete.
Se una persona con autismo
non capisce subito
quello che le state dicendo,
provate a spiegarlo in modo più chiaro,
magari utilizzando altre parole,
magari utilizzando delle immagini;
o semplicemente,
da un altro punto di vista".
Non giudichiamo, quindi:
cambiamo il nostro sguardo.
Perché il mondo ha bisogno
di tutti i tipi di mente.
(Applausi)